if you like seeing video games brought
to life in wreck-it Ralph you are going
to go crazy for seeing the world of the
internet brought to life and Ralph
breaks the Internet rekka Ralph - is
away these students this film is being
created by the team who brought you the
original record Ralph and they're fresh
off their oscar-winning work on Zootopia
please welcome directors rich Moore and
Phil Johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
the original film was a love letter to
video game arcades a place that I spent
a lot of time and money in as a kid and
when we thought about where to take
these characters next we knew we had to
go somewhere big big big big yeah it to
be big big bigger better so this time
Ralph and his Salvin LP are going to
escape the arcade world and enter a
whole new universe the enormous and
exciting world of the Internet and here
to tell you more about that where'd you
see this the voice of vanellope von
schweetz our dear friend the
incomparable Sarah Silverman
[Applause]
in our story vanilla pees game sugar
rush breaks and Ralph and vanellope have
to travel into the internet and find a
replacement part it's the only way to
save the game right absolutely what is
really awesome about that is that we got
the actual actresses who played the
princesses in the original fields to
come back and voice their iconic
characters for that scene isn't that
great
not great all right everybody's got a
picture
[Music]
the real Disney Princesses ladies and
una
you
you